[Music]
okay so we'll start
I did do length squared sampling that is
already done so that's the matrix
multiplication theorem I'll put this up
and then we'll use it for the compressed
representation of a matrix which we went
through fast we'll go through this
carefully so I take a B I want to find
this product this is the estimate the
spectral long I'm sorry the Frobenius
norm so is less than or equal to was
quite root of s of course this is random
variable it's an expectation but just to
remember if I pick s samples to multiply
i data goes down as root s1 over all
this okay that we will use when we do
the compress sensing so compress not a
not compressing sorry compression
complex representation so this was just
recap this is what we are doing now is
an N by n matrix big potentially big in
both dimensions m and n will show
without assumptions on a will show that
a can be approximated provided you give
me just a sample of rows of a and a
sample of columns of a but the sampling
has been linked squared to get
reasonable error bounds right if the
sampling is done with arbitrary
probabilities then we don't know good
error bounds you can always get a bound
on the variance but it won't be so good
at all okay then we went through the
intuition let me go through the
intuition faster and then we'll get to
the formal proof we didn't do so I'll do
that now
so first can we just pick a sample of
rows we said no because there also don't
tell us anything for our sample rules
but if the rank is K H is very small and
if rows are in general position if I
pick a large multiple of K I should pin
down the row space basically I should
get everybody in their own space right
by that point but we still don't know
for unsampled row what linear
combination of the sample rows it is and
here was a picture right size sample
these rows and here's another row
unsampled I know nothing about this from
the information I have on dose however
we said intuitively this if I picked a
sample of 100 K columns as well that
should be sufficient so I pick a lot of
columns then I know all these entries
and I want these entries if things are
in general position now these entries
I want these these are so many equations
but there are enough unknowns that
that's easy to solve pinned down right
sorry there are more equations than
unknowns so because this is 100k okay
and the rank is only K so there are K
unknowns hundred K equations there in
general position you should be able to
pin it down so that was the idea and we
want to rigorously prove it so here is a
picture big a sample of columns sample
of rows and the assertion is from the
sample rows and columns I can find a
matrix you to put in here right so that
the product is approximately right and
you know if there are as columns and s
rows it says bias this thing this won't
be diagonal if I did SVD we'll see later
or spectral decomposition this will be
dying all right spectral decomposition
you are all familiar
diagonal entries will be eigen values in
singular value decomposition which will
see the diagonal entries will be
singular values and it'll be zero of
tangle but this will not be zero of
diagonal okay so we gave this example I
won't run through the example again but
the example was to illustrate that the
norm we want to bound is a spectral law
so we want this approximation to have
the property that the spectral norm is
bounded that's a correct norm just based
on this motivation and we'll see about
that goes
to the 1/3 in the square so if I take
square roots s to the 1/6 as opposed to
root s it's worse convergence but we are
doing more because we are compressed we
are approximating any matrix ok so now
the idea this we went through again but
I'll recap and then we'll prove things
today the idea is this I'm going to do a
funny thing I'm going to pretend I'm
multiplying a with the identity matrix
right which of course I won't do but I
put let's pretend that and I'm going to
apply this result matrix multiplication
result to that pretend multiplication
that's what we're going to do right so
we are multiplying a with I sampling by
sampling s columns of a ok then the
error from here is the Frobenius norm of
Haydn's for vinius normal where i
divided by root s right that's this one
but the Frobenius on high is rooting for
me nice norm squared is n right these
are sum of squares well the entry is
root n so this doesn't do much good
because I need us to be at least n to
get any sensible result right getting
another of AF is not sensible I could
have just output 0 right for a and got
an error but most this much so that's
not interesting so to get anything
interesting I have to see I seem to have
to make s and or greater so that's not
good
now we picked remember all was the set
of rows we picked a bunch of rows are
our trans forces are small matrix we
picked our rows so it's an r by r matrix
we assume it's invertible
now let's again intuitively true so R
has I mean only R rows right if they has
high enough rank okay forget the ranking
I'm going to do it in general now if a
is high enough rank this should be
independent if in general position right
and then our our transpose will be
invertible as long as the rows are
independent so we assume that if it's
not just as an aside the full proof does
not assume it but will only do the proof
in this is
if you don't assume it you have to do
something called the pseudo-inverse and
I won't do that I'll assume it's
invertible then now look at this matrix
P this is just a projection matrix so
it's R transpose R R transpose inverse R
this acts as the identity on the row
space of R so what I'm going to do is
replace the eye which is bad with a P
and P is an identity look-alike right so
because it is the identity on that on a
subspace so why is that so that's a
proof here so suppose V is a subspace
spanned by the rows of our then I want
to prove that P axis identity and it
proof is simple so since X is in the row
space of our it can be written like that
X transpose can be written as a
combination of rows of our so px you
just write it down you get that right
and then our transpose inverse and our
transpose cancel out and you get our
transpose Y which is just exits of so it
actually does access the identity as
cleaned and for vectors in the
orthogonal complement it that's directly
there deli the null space of P so P X is
0 because R X is 0 right so X is
orthogonal to the row space of our so
our X is 0 so it is 0 so instead of
pretend a I do pretend AP will prove two
things which today that imply we want to
prove that a minus C u R is small will
prove two steps first a minus AP small
so this is going to come from this
theorem right so I'm pretend multiplying
a times P to get an approximation to a
itself because P is like the identity so
this theorem will tell us is small ok
that's step one and the second step is
is going to prove that AP minus C you
are small so if you add these together
by triangle inequality you bound a minus
C R which is what we want to do so why
is this so this is another application
of this theorem
so suppose C is the length squared
sample of columns of a that's what we
started with okay then we'll see that
the corresponding rows of a rosa p
excuse me
can be written as u times r and the hint
for this is p ends in R so P is actually
something times R so if I pick some rows
of P that's like some u times are all is
there for us at the end right so this is
small because I'm multiplying a and B by
a a times P by sampling that's I'm
sampling a columns of a let's see and
sampling corresponding rows of P that's
U times R so there will be a second
application of this right so together it
will give us a result so this hastily I
told you this last time but now I'm
going to go over the proof of this so
again it puts a simple but once you have
this so I'm gonna go with that okay so a
proposition first P acts like the
identity but only in a small subspace so
but will still claim that a and AP are
roughly equal if it's completely that
interview have been exactly equal but
that's not true so in other words I want
us P's a random variables so I'm going
to assert that they expected operators
spectral norm is small one over root R
times that and why is that a minus AP
squared is that is this is just a
definition of the spectral law max
overall unit length vectors of a minus
AP x squared now two cases X could be in
the row space of our then we saw that px
is the peas identity so px is X so a px
is just a X and so it's 0 that's no
problem I'm trying to prove the norm is
small its 0 is very good okay to 0
vector so the norm is 0 so so we need to
consider only vectors in the orthogonal
complement space because every vector is
the sum of something in V and V
so the max is attained by somebody in V
perp right orthogonal complement of Li
and in that space P X is zero we saw
that that's all the null space of P so a
minus a px is just a X right px becomes
zero so now I have to bound a X okay for
a subspace orthogonal to R so X is
orthogonal to R the rough idea what is
this thing the rough idea what is what
I'm going to say I'm going to say X is
small
I picked a sample of rolls of a and I'm
saying everybody I'll talk enough to
just a sample actually is fairly
orthogonal to itself
that's what does this thing right if X
is fairly orthogonal to aid will be 0
this so it's saying if it's all tolerant
to a sample it's actually our toggle
merely to aids of makes sense sense but
it's going to be important it's length
squared otherwise it's not going to be
true right it's not true if you pick a
random sample the variance is high right
so if you had some rules that are very
heavy and other of those are all 0 the
sample doesn't tell you much but length
squared is enough to produce so here is
the proof of that so I'm going to write
ax squared as X transpose a transpose ax
right and I'm going to rewrite that as X
transpose a transpose a minus R
transpose R X so why is this true
anybody want to take a guess all our X
is 0 so I only added there also a
subtractive 0 that's fine
ok so that by definition is at most the
spectral norm of a and it's like vector
norm of a transpose a minus R transpose
R ok and I want to say this is small I
want to say a transpose a minus R
transpose R small R is just a bunch of
rows of a I picked at random any idea
what might make this small how would I
prove that
so why is it that if I pick a bunch of
rules that random but length squared
this then this is a good approximation
to this inspector long let's say yeah so
it's this one right I am multiplying a
transpose by a by sampling some columns
of a transpose which are just rows away
that's my our transpose right I'm taking
the corresponding rows of a which is our
so this this is small because of the
matrix multiplication theorem because of
this I'm not actually doing it right
this is only for the proof I'm not
actually multiplying a transpose by a so
suffice has to prove that this is small
matrix multiplication theorem why again
I didn't write down all of the Y but I
am again so to do multiplication of a
transpose times a I have to pick random
columns of a transpose which are rows of
a length squared
rows away and that's our and I must take
this corresponding rows away this a and
that's far again and so okay sorry we
should so I'm multiplying a transpose B
a so this perviness norm of a squared
but in the square it's fourth power it
were being divided by root R but in the
square it's divided our right that's all
I'm saying so this is an expectation I I
was sloppy here this is expectation
right these are random variables yes
yeah okay sorry good point
so in fact I am asserting I am this is
even this is a bit weaker this is even
Frobenius norm right it turns out okay
I'm not able to use the Frobenius norm
because all I have here is two I cannot
for this part I cannot assert Frobenius
norm okay because of this Cedars way of
doing X in this space or that I'm only
proving for a single X so I'm not trying
to be nice mom so excuse me I should
have said that but two norm is always
smaller than
I mean maybe I should write down little
proof so 2 norm is x max X transpose ax
well not a x squared right is equal to X
transpose a transpose a and then one
thing you can do is apply cauchy-schwarz
and you get that so I maybe I won't
write down the proof please go home and
do prove this that the spectral norm is
at most of for being Islam so I get that
and then so that's just what I said
already and it's written down there more
carefully so okay so excuse me
let's go back one man so I have proved
here so far only this right I only prove
this I have to prove the other part of
the bug in there were two inequalities
to prove a P and C you are roughly equal
now this is proved again by applying
this so C is the length squared sample
of columns of a want to pick
corresponding rules of P see I'm
multiplying a and P I pick columns of a
which form C I must speak the
corresponding rows of P but P is of this
form
okay so if I pick some rows of P I can
always write that as u times R right
I'll leave the are alone and I pick some
rows of all of this and that's my you
all I have to notice is that there's an
hour at the end
so that tells you how to find you as
well so you you find you by taking the
rules of this quantity and the error is
now now in Frobenius norm because I'm
multiplying matrices a and P I get that
and I have to divide by s because I
picked s samples I'm still to bound this
quantity provenience normal P I don't
know what it is right I have to get rid
of that so bounding this P has rank R P
is P is there so we assumed our is full
rank that's why I could write the
inverse and R has our rules so the rank
of P is also our little small alright
and we saw it access identity on an R
dimensional subspace and the rest is
null space any such matrix s for Venus
no are again you should prove that at
home but it's very simple right it's
basically just identity or dimensional
identity right because 0 so it's an
automation identity matrix which has
Frobenius norm squared R sorry I mean
it's not squid are just all ones on the
diagonal in the correct basis if you
write it on the right piece putting this
together you get okay so this error is
our bias that our bias because the top
you get in our there this goes out
always the other error is 1 over root R
so the optimal choice of R is s to the
2/3 right the optimal choice of our this
to the 2/3 that just a little calculus
like you basically if you to terms like
that you make them equal right that's
the best choice I mean you can do
differentiation and make sure
differentiate with respect to R keeping
s fixed and you see that our zester's
with it it's the best choice and so then
we get the theorem I'm going to just
list
yeah it was a question oh so a is an M
by n matrix RNs or positive integers C
is an M by s matrix of columns length
squared sampling our is length squared
sampling of rows R and s are not
necessarily equal and the conclusion is
we can find from seeing R and s by M s
power matrix u so that this is valid
this is true for any R and s right so of
course it makes no sense if R is greater
than s you get a huge error you can make
it greater than s is it still true that
theorem but it doesn't tell you much but
the best choice of R is yesterda to that
okay so that's only the specular law
there is also a bound on the Frobenius
norm which I didn't write down if
there's time later I can go with that
but maybe that's all I want to say for
now before I'm going on to the next
lecture I mean next topic which is SVD
so this is not the best you can do now I
believe there are better results I can
give you references for for this right
so there are better things than this to
be said
right so good point so the if I wanted
to do one multiplication of a in a
transpose then it's true that length
squared was optimal okay so this length
squared will still do length squared so
length square is optimal once you fix
the number of samples you take that's
still going to be the case except you'll
fix the number of samples slightly
differently and the argument changes but
I don't remember actually all the
changes part of the answer part of I
don't know the precise answer actually I
should look up the papers but yeah so
okay so that's good that's right
so there's a whole new subject in some
sense length squared is not the only
thing you can do it turns out there's I
mean later methods now do adaptive
sampling roughly adaptive sampling you
can think of so length squared picked
one vector with probability proportional
to length squared I don't know whether I
showed this to you but you can instead
pick pairs of vectors with probability
proportional to the area of the triangle
that you would like to spend so length
squared is a one-dimensional measure
right instead I could look at all the
pairs of rows and pick that pick pairs
with probability proportional to the
area squared or more you can pick three
tuples of rows with probably
proportional to the square of the wall
you move the simplex am close and so so
this wall is called determinantal
process volume sampling that turns out
to be much better results but takes a
long time and also the proofs are harder
I won't do this in this course but I
mean I can give a reference
how do we construct you so going back to
the yeah so I I picked okay I picked
some columns of a to make my see up I
want to pick the same rows of P which is
the same as picking exactly those rows
of our transpose so our transpose a long
skinny matrix because our was flat so I
want to pick the rows of our transpose
which correspond to the columns of C so
my U then is I do that and then hit it
with our our transpose inverse to
compute it I have to find our transpose
inverse one thing I should have said I
mean maybe there's a good question to
answer right I should have said write
the computational effort so you got the
sample and do all these things but the
computational effort is mainly finding
the inverse of this matrix but this is a
small matrix this is r by r so I do have
to compute the inverse of that the rest
of the time I'm only doing samples and
taking the samples and putting them
together and so on but this one
competition I have to do
the optimal choice of all may not be
this yes it's also possible I didn't
prove
Oh what did he do is a slow rank no no I
two things I don't know meaning so if K
is exactly rank K I mean the day is
exactly rank K then you know so you're
asking can you can I do with less than K
rows or something like that right
I don't know that so right now it is
independent of the rank of K right so
that's right yeah so okay for the
Frobenius norm there is a best possible
approximation by sweidy if I go to rank
K and the bound I did not write down
instead of this will say I can come
within this much of the best there you
will need a number of sample size
depends it has to depend on K it will be
larger than K but it has to depend on K
so the result would be I can if I draw
it as samples but depending on cake I'll
get a bound on the right hand side which
is the best rank K approximation you can
ever get plus some more I maybe I should
have written that down but I can yeah
there are there are results like that
square root of there yeah yeah so right
so if you want to put I think you're
saying that if I want to put the
right-hand side only the spectral norm
so I have to use this time this is less
than or equal to the rank of a time's
the spectral all right that's what
you're saying right yeah so we will
actually prove that when we do this we D
but yeah so so actually maybe everybody
should try to prove that or recall that
from linear algebra that the Frobenius
norm is that most squared is at most the
rank of a times that but we'll prove
that when we do SVD so you're not
already up on it will prove that so I
could have written that in terms of that
but I look pretty bad right the rank
could be M or M whichever as high as
that so then the bound doesn't look very
good which is true I mean so I should
mention that you cannot put just
operator norm here without the M or n
that's not possible
so yes you can you do get concentration
okay so with some catches right you get
concentration of the fact that the s
choices of columns are independent
that's all
there's only s degrees of Independence
or R degrees that's all
and the SNR are thought to be constants
right so you only get that much
concentration so then we switch to the
next next file see four columns and our
four rows but I guess yeah it's not the
best it's curse or something right yeah
yours might be you could put an e at the
end then it would be cure but I mean I
just called it C or curse or color or
something yeah okay singular value
decomposition so I'm going to do it this
in a self-contained manner now I mean
clearly you know everybody knows that
algebra linear algebra covers
unfortunately often does not cover SVD
right you do spectral decomposition and
so on but not necessarily SVD somehow a
sweetie is more useful in terms of
handling data because you know it's you
know cents more useful than eigen values
eigen vectors of course there are
different purposes but it's less covered
so let's see one definition of SVD there
are many equivalent definitions I'm
going to start with one angle you have n
data points in D space each represented
as a row of a data matrix I guess I had
called it columns at some point part
sorry this chapter we called it row so
it's an N by D matrix each row has one
data point singular value decomposition
is going to consist of the best fit K
dimensional subspace for the data for
every K K equals 1 to up to rank of a
where best fit means this
it means I minimize the sum of squared
perpendicular distances of the data
points to the subspace okay now we will
see that which is not obvious that SVD
gives you the best fit for every K
simultaneously perhaps we draw a picture
so your data points are here so you have
a subspace of dimension two so since
it's a subspace the origin must be in on
it this is a subspace so we take the sum
of squared perpendicular distances so we
project we take for each point its
distance perpendicular distance to the
plane right perpendicular to the claim
this plane right I square them each
square and add again the square is
important right and add them the I'd
like to say so that's the same as and
we'll have another picture the next
slide that's the same as if we maximize
the sum of squares of the length of the
projection of the data points into the
subspace that's the same as taking this
is the length of the projection and for
instance for this from the origin to
that right in that space I think I have
a better picture on the next slide so I
take those projections Square and sum
they are the same we'll see a picture
will make it obvious so this is the
picture right so this is a data point a
I this is my one dimensional subspace
because easy to draw V so I either take
these distances square them and add and
minimize them or take these projections
square them and add and maximize them
right and they are they give you the
same result because courtesy progress
because the sum of squares of these two
a fixed constant independent of the
subspace that I'm worried about right so
it's just the length of a I squared
therefore I can think of it as
maximizing so for example this is the
first advantage of using sum of square
projections or distances right it's not
true if I use distances or projection
lengths now we have to contrast this
just to make sure we see the difference
in calculus we look at least squares fit
and that's slightly different right so
at least squares fit is what yeah a
bunch of points the plane this is X I Y
I you want to fit a best linear function
to this and now the distance is the
vertical distances right I mean that's
what that's what this is not distances
perpendicular to this line right so it's
different
I mean least squares again you have
squares for a reason right you remember
when you differentiate it will be a
linear set of equations so it's easier
to solve something like that will happen
here that's why you have squares there's
a bigger there's a perhaps a bigger
difference in the usual least squares
fit the line doesn't have to go to the
origin right least squares fit I'll be
careful to call that least squares and
what we have best set at least squares
will go away from it I'm not worried
about that right
so in these queries you don't require
the line to go to the origin but in SVD
you do it's a subspace so it has to go
through the origin so you may wonder
whether that's a good idea
suppose my points actually look like
this the best one-dimensional fit the
best fit is also some line like this
which doesn't pass through the origin
right we require that to pass for the
origin I get a bad fit okay that may
bother you but it'll turn out it's not
very difficult to prove this we won't do
it now I'll do it later
is that in fact if I want the best fit
line not necessarily passing through the
origin you
can show that the line must actually
pass through the centroid of the data
centroid is just average of all these
things so these data points averages
some a here you can show that the best
fit line actually passes through the
centroid so you can try that as an
exercise this time later we'll come and
do it just just a simple exercise so in
fact if you took any line and translated
it parallel to itself it passes through
the centroid that's the best translation
just best parallel translation that you
can do just you prove it by writing this
down that's true for any dimensional
subspace actually if I if now I'm
sitting with points in 3d and I want to
find the best plane fit then you can
prove that the best one passes through
the centroid if it then you can
translate and gain okay therefore if you
want it the best find space or fine
means any translate of a subspace a fine
space you should take the centroid you
can find it by taking averages and do
the translation before you apply its VD
so if somebody just put all the traffic
you know put all the data way out they
translated doing SVD may not be a good
idea you'll get a line like this but you
really want to get that so that's called
centering data we'll go through the
proof of this you can easily do it for
lines for I dimensional spaces it's just
only a calculation we'll do it later
so the best the most important thing is
for a sweetie will show that the greedy
algorithm what's the greedy algorithm is
find the best fit one dimensional
subspace to the data line through the
origin then fine then find the best fit
line through the origin again
perpendicular to the first line so if
the data where it's difficult to draw if
the later data lie on a plane like this
a coplanar then you would like to find
both axes of this plane so
if you do this process you'll find it to
access by the way this is probably one
of the earliest or the earliest greedy
algorithm so it's an important really
algorithm we'll see that it works
correctly but it's you know it dates
back to before minimum spanning tree and
all those things
it's very so at the IDE step so second
step you look for a line best fit line
through the origin subspace again
perpendicular to the first at the ID
step you look for the best fit line
perpendicular to the once you've got
already you keep doing this until rank
of a I reaches rank of a and we'll show
that when we are done so I'm going to
write down just because some of you may
be familiar from learning algebra with
the matrix factorization version don't
pay any attention to it because that's
not the viewpoint we want to take but in
any case at the end of the day you could
write a as a fact as a product of three
matrices where the columns of V or these
lines or these lines you found these are
diagonal matrix with positive entries in
spectral decomposition B would have been
the eigenvalues now it's singular values
which will define and the columns of U
and V are orthonormal this is called SVD
again now focus just on the best fit
lines forget the matrix factorization
we'll come back to it okay
okay first singular vector write
notation this just recall is an N by D
matrix each row of the data point so if
you use the unit vector along the best
fit line we know that again I'm just
recapping this V minimizes among all
unit legs vectors the distance from the
data point a to the line through X right
to the line with X as the unit vector in
the direction X so this is just the
projection on X I subtract out the
projection from the link and that's the
distance so the distance is this
and again photographer this is just
redoing it again this summed over all I
is a constant is just
of the length of rules squared is just a
if it doesn't depend on X so I may
discard that okay I have a minus sign a
minimizing so that's like maximizing ax
squared so we define that to be our
first singular vector so we take the
maximum overall unit length vectors of a
V the length of it it's the same as
that's fit minimizing the sum of squared
distances right so I should have had a
square there because I'm minimizing and
maximizing the sum of squared
projections but you know maximizing
something squared is the same as
maximizing the absolute value of course
you the answer is great but result is
the same okay
there can be ties there could be
multiple V wants actually a simple
question or they're going to be twice or
maybe sometimes there won't be what's an
obvious there is always a tie what's an
obvious tie - we won right so if you put
a minus 4 eigen values also that's true
I can back then negative of that or
bowtie in vectors is the same I can
value right you choose one so there can
be ties we break ties arbitrarily so
there's odd max is not unique okay and
the singular value is just a link so you
can views a singular value as how much a
magnifies any vector the maximum amount
a magnifies the length of any vector
so you know if you draw the isotherms
the curve curves along which you get the
same value of a V it'll be an ellipsoid
I didn't define ellipsoid and all that
but this the longest axis will be the
first thing your the value so ignore
this picture if you're not familiar but
that's called the first thing in the
value of a if data okay one thing I
should say we will show that the
singular values are unique okay there's
no even if there are ties for the
singular vector the singular values are
unique we'll see that later if the data
points all lie on a line through the
origin the line on which the projections
of X mice is precisely that line if the
data points are collinear on a line
through the origin you will get that
line right that's where the projection
is maximized so that's the first single
vector so now what happens is the data
points are coplanar rather than
collinear we'd like to get the two
perpendicular direction spanning the
plane so that motivates this definition
we want to define further single vectors
so think of coplanar data it really
would like the two dimensional subspace
maximizing the sum of squared
projections so we want to take points
project them down this is the origin so
we want to maximize these lengths
squared sum of these lengths played
right now let's say for the moment I
don't know how to find two dimensions of
spaces which do this maximization I can
do a try to do a Grady we can define a
second singular vector v2 as the one and
here break ties arbitrarily again which
maximizes the sum of squared projections
but has to be perpendicular to the first
vector little algebra shows you that's
the same as this right so again it would
have been a square there but I don't
care to put the square so now we 2 is
the maximum V perpendicular to V 1 of
length 1 that does that and V 3 is
to be perpendicular to both v1 and v2
that maximizes this and then you define
the second singular value as how much
the magnification you get here in the v2
direction third single value how much
magnification you get in the three
direction and so on and you go on until
it's zero that is to say I found we went
through we are the every V perpendicular
to that makes there isn't a null space
Ray makes zero product with a right then
you stop R will be the rank of a will
prove that later and more importantly if
this is not obvious even if there were
ties for the singular vectors the
singular values are unique right
I mean it's avatars I could have gone
down different parts for choosing
singular vectors there's no simple
reason right away that the singular
values are unique but we'll see that
they are ok no so they are invariant
they're invariants of the matrix so they
do not depend on the singular vector I
choose it was advertised so I may have
you know multiple choices of each single
vector whatever choice whichever way I
come down the tree so the main gist of
this most important theorem is that the
greedy algorithm works so let's define
the best state k dimensional subspace
again just turn it already as the one
maximizing the sum of squared projection
lengths of data points into the subspace
maximized over all K dimensional
subspaces
the theorem says the following it says a
really algorithm what's that you have
this and I've defined singular vectors
so again greedy because I picked the
best single V one best single V two
perpendicular to it and so on I didn't
pay attention to
projections in the K dimensional space
just one at a time I paid attention to
though it's greedy so for K equals one
to our vkb the subspace spanned by the
singular vectors again there could have
been ties and we picked one choice but
any choice for each K the assertion is
we K is the best fit k dimensional
subspace for a now I shouldn't say
necessarily D it can be a right there
could be many best fit subspaces there
could be theis right so when when you
want examples for things like that the
identity is a good example lots of ties
for the identity right every single
value is one and so this is this is what
we will prove now again this is one of
that they said I would say this is the
earliest greedy algorithm so it's very
important historically as well as useful
wise very important proof by induction
on K statement is obvious for K equals 1
right so for K equals 1 one dimensional
subspace by definition that's the best
so we prove that
let's do K equals 2 suppose W is the
best fit two dimensional subspace I like
to prove somehow that v2 I found v1 and
v2 they're span is capital V 2 I like to
say v2 is the best is not be best again
there can be ties here I assume W is the
best I must prove that be tooth at least
as good as first job a little technical
claim there is a w2 belonging to W so
that it's perpendicular to V 1 perhaps a
little picture here
so here is the origin here is we won and
I have a two dimensional subspace W the
assertion is there's a w-2 in this
subspace length one is not a big problem
w2 somewhere which is perpendicular to
this and the reason is I project me one
onto this and I can take that angles to
be ninety degrees although it doesn't
look like that
so because the projection of V 100 W
spans at most one dimensional space and
you can take it all thought it could the
picture is need not be quite like this
the picture could be that v1 is
perpendicular to W then I can take
anybody here W to choose any w1 which is
perpendicular to w2 so W 2 is here and I
choose w1 could be this one right scale
to 1 and so that W 1 W 2 former basis
they are perpendicular in length 1 so by
convention
sometimes by basis you only mean a set
of orthonormal vectors which are I mean
they are all linked 1 right so I don't I
won't have to repeat length 1 so basis
is going to mean that now now is so I'm
trying to prove that V Tuesday's good as
W 2 W 2 is the length some of the square
projections on the W equals this and
that's just because so I have the height
data point a I its projection onto W
squared is just a I dot W 1 squared plus
a I dot W 2 squared W 1 W 2 is a basis
so I take the component
on the two basis vectors and square and
anthem that's what I get that
and then I some lower all I I will just
get that the squares are important now I
want to assert this is true that v1 is
at least as good as w1 so why is that v1
is the best right yeah how about this we
choose at least as good as w2
so we - was the best among everything
this was perpendicular to V one and we
made sure W two is perpendicular to V 1
so V 2 is the best among that lot
therefore it must be better than this
right we add the two and this is what W
thing is and this is what V 2 the
Capitol vetoes protection is so V 2 is
at least as good so that's a proof for K
equals 2 and now I want to prove for K
higher right so the inductive hypothesis
we're going to assume it's good for K
minus 1 and I want to prove for K so
again it's more or less the same proof I
assume that W is the best at k
dimensional subspace let's say and I
want to claim this lemma raised here I
want to claim there's a unit vector W K
in W perpendicular to VK minus 1 so W is
a k-dimensional space and V sub K minus
1 I can't draw fully either one
dimension lower there's somebody here
perpendicular to all of that it's just
the dimension count right
so W case perpendicular to all of that
so now we choose the basis W 1 to wk of
W you can always take a vector and
complete it to a basis right and so you
can choose these orthogonal to this and
so on
so it's W and now take the first K minus
1 I want to claim this is the length of
squared projections on W except for the
last one right that's less than or equal
to that ok why is that
that's the inductive assumption right so
we came minus 1 capital VK minus 1 of
which this is the basis was the best K
minus 1 dimensional subspace we assumed
inductively and this is a KD this is the
K minus 1 dimensional subspace so this
must be better than that and that's by
induction we also have this and that is
again because VK was the best am i
everything perpendicular to V 1 through
VK minus 1 and wk was perpendicular to
all of those two therefore this is
better than that as you see the proof is
very simple right I mean and then you
just add you're done right so the
consequence is so I guess if you're
looking at the book usually everything
I've done is there but this one we
didn't do what so I'll spend a few
minutes trying to prove that the theorem
also proves that the singular values are
unique even if there were ties to the
singular vectors why is that Sigma 1 is
unique but before unique you have to
prove that it exists right it was a
maximum over infinitely many things
right Sigma 1 was the max over all max
over all unit length vectors of AF a set
of unit length vectors is closed and
bounded right so so so we know that the
maximum is attained otherwise maximum is
attained and F Sigma Bonnie so is
defined and exists and is unique now
there is a unique value of the maximum
over 2d subspaces of the sum of
projection square onto the subspace now
this is a little trickier so the set of
2d subspaces is closed and bounded it
doesn't look like that right subspaces
are unbounded well I'll show you on the
next slide that this is a reasonable
thing to do right so
that that this Mewtwo exists so call
that Mewtwo right so we have to prove
that Mewtwo exists right for that we
have to prove that the maximum is
attained it is in fact attained even
though it looks like the set of
subspaces are not bounded but it's it's
true we'll see that so let's assume you
two exist then theorem say said that's
Mewtwo and that's equal to that right so
mu 2 Sigma 2 squared is just mu 2 minus
that this is unique this is unique so
this is unique and in general by
induction these are these are assumed to
unique mu k be the maximum over all K
dimensional subspaces of the sum of
squared projections into the subspace
and the theorem implies that this is
equal to me okay
provided mu k exists right again we have
to prove that using the inductive
hypothesis now we see that Sigma K is
unique so I have to prove to you mu K
exists so let's do that exercise I mean
this is not very relevant normally you
just assume that after having done
whatever advanced calculus but let's
just go with this proof right so I want
to prove that a sequence of subspaces
has a convergent subsequence right so we
have V 1 or oh these are not my V 1
excuse me these are just any infinite
sequence of K dimensional subspaces of
Rd so I should have called them
something else I want to prove that
there is a convergent subsequence and
the caution is that the subject
subspace is simply unbounded objects but
what you do is you choose a basis for
each VI and then first take a
subsequence of the sequence of bases or
the sequence of subspaces in which the
first basis vector converges the basis
vectors are unit length objects right so
they are closed bounded it's a closed
bounded set so there is a sub sequence
that converges and then take the
subsequence of the subsequence where the
second basis vector converges again
second basis vector unit length
everything is bounded closed so you can
repeat that
process and finally get a subsequence
with each basis vector converging and
you you have to do a little proof that
in the limit the the limit of a bunch of
vectors of length 1 is still of length 1
right
also the limit of a bunch of basis
vectors is still orthogonal but these
are obvious just Lipschitz is true they
they don't change much okay yeah so this
wasn't a site just just so jog your
memory of calculus right so but it does
need a proof because it's not obvious
that sort of space the sequence of
spaces or the convergence of sequence ok
so let's see if I forgot something
I didn't forget anything I I don't know
what that I'm accelerating but anyway I
think I have enough slide so I can go on
okay so singular values are norm so a v1
is a list of links with signs of the
projections of the rows of a right so I
take each row and project onto v1 that's
each component of a v1 so Sigma 1 a
which is the length of that vector you
can think of it as if it was a component
of a along V 1 so each row of this this
vector each row of this is a component
of one data point along v1 together you
can think of this as sort of the
projection of the component of the data
along we want Sigma 2 similarly you can
think of as a component of V along a
along V 2 the data on V 2 now this is
sounding like decomposing a vector into
its component along basis vectors right
you know since that's what we're doing
and if that analogy is to carry over
so for a vector you have that you take
the component along the basis vectors
square and add you get the length right
so you better have the same thing here
sum of squares the components equal to
the whole then the analogy would be good
so let's see if that's true
and that is in fact right so I'm going
to take each a I projected along each of
the singular vectors and add after
squaring but first observe that if I had
a vector V orthogonal to all the all
vectors a I dot B is 0 because remember
we stopped when we couldn't find
anything I'll toggle so these are all 0
therefore the length of a I squared is
just as component along all the basis
vectors squared because you really have
to take the other vectors orthogonal to
V T but there aren't any which make any
nonzero product so this is true and you
just now add up so I think I did a
little bit of calculation here so I add
up all the rows of all the data points
each one is the data point
so I just take the product with each
singular vector they exchange the sums
here and now this thing is the length of
this thing summed over all the data
points is that okay so those are just
Sigma I squared so that proves that
little lemma that the Frobenius norm
squared so if I this thing is the sum of
squares of all the entries array right
which we call the Frobenius norm squared
so I took the sum of squares in row J
but I summed over all J so that's just
equal to sum of squares of all the
increase the Frobenius norm and we
approve that that's the sum of squares
our singular values so that actually
proves this that proves this because R
is equal to the rank of a and one other
thing I didn't write down
and Sigma 1 squared a so I guess I
should have written down this sorry this
quantity singular value is just also the
spectrum all right we define spectral
norm earlier it's the same definition I
think the top singular value is equal to
the spectrum oh I should have written
that down and then we have Sigma 1
squared is greater than or equal to
Sigma 2 squared and that's by definition
right this is the best overall this is
the best perpendicular to the first
transform so they're not sending order
descending order therefore you get that
from that right because the this left
hand side some of the T equals 1 2 or
Sigma T squared a is less like our times
Sigma 1 square
okay so I'm going to complete a 3b
that's what's going to happen in the
next few slides I'm going to tell you
how to put this together to get to
singular value decomposition so right
and left singular vectors right so we
these V is vent on the right hand side
of a so they call right singular vectors
the vectors a VI will give us left
singular vectors so in the case of eigen
values if you had a eigen vector V you
got lambda V so when I hit an eigen
vector with a you get the same back to
collinear but in the case of singular
vectors that's not necessarily true
in fact there is one simple reason why
it's true why it's not true a might be
rectangular
so a might be like that right so V would
be a small vector a V would be a long
way so even the dimensions of E and AV
don't match I can values are defined
eigen vectors are only defined for
square matrices right so singular values
are defined I should have said their
very own singular values are defined for
rectangular matrices of course because
remember the rows were data so the
number of data points and dimension will
not be the same in our business so we
went to via or call the right singular
vectors and the vectors a times VI form
of fundamental set of vectors
I call them UI after normalizing so a VI
has length Sigma V remember that's how
we defined it I normalized to length 1 I
get you I will show later that UI or
very analogous to VI so you I behaved as
if they were more or less the same thing
except on the other side right so u
transpose V overall u perpendicular to
that so they maximize new transpose V
sorry u transpose a which is the same as
a transpose u so I should have said you
or the singular vectors or the right
singular vectors of a transpose
you eye or wheel have to prove this
right singular vectors you I call the
left singular vectors now of a right by
definition the right single vectors for
orthogonal the V 1 to V are orthogonal
because I define V 2 to be orthogonal to
V 1 V 3 to be orthogonal to both those
and so on right will show later that the
left singular vectors are also
orthogonal we won't show that yet now I
come to what probably you know it's an
important thing and it has a lot of uses
right it's called a singular value
decomposition in in the case of eigen
values you've heard a spectral
decomposition it's sort of similar they
are related but I won't tell you the
relation yet because I want to focus
just on singular edges singular vectors
I don't want to say it's somehow sort of
copy of eigenvalues and eigenvectors no
it's not but so by the way even for
square matrices the eigen values and
eigenvectors can be quite different from
singular values and singular vectors so
for instance if you know what's called
PageRank where Google decides how to
rank pages that's based on an
eigenvector you don't get anything good
if you base that on a singular vectors
away there are other cases where
singular vectors are useful they can be
quite different so a the matrix any
matrix VT and UT and Sigma T this is a
theorem I'm going to state the singular
value decomposition theorem or they this
notation they've already introduced or
the right singular vectors left singular
vectors and singular values then the
singular value decomposition SVD theorem
says is exactly equal and RSA is the is
the end right I mean there's no more
after that exactly equal to Sigma T
which are all non-negative
right times u T times V T transpose u T
is a column vector V T is also a column
vector V transpose is a row vector so
this is an outer product namely each of
those things looks like u T V T that so
the product is a full-fledged matrix
right full dimensional matrix it's a sum
of those is exactly equal to the sum of
those right that's what we want to prove
the proof won't be hard we have already
set up many things first first off or
the proof so to prove that two matrices
are identical this and that I want to
prove they're the same it's enough to
prove or it's if and only if they
operating on any vector they do the same
thing so they applied to thee and be
applied to V give you the same vector
this is one-line proof of that right so
we see that if a V equals B V for all V
in particulate holds for the unit
vectors of the columns are the same the
Congress is very simple okay so now we
will use this we want to prove a and B
are the same where B is this we want to
show that a V equals B V for all V and
so it's enough to show okay this is
another standard thing in linear algebra
right when you want to so show a bunch
of linear equations hold it's enough to
show it for basis vectors
everybody's a linear combination of them
so that's so you don't have to show for
a set of V forming a basis of space
we're going to take a convenient basis
which consists of the singular vectors
we want through we are but then we run
out of them right there are only out of
them they may not spend the whole space
right a may not be full rank so they may
not spend all of this way all the d
dimensional space we complete the basis
with other vectors we can always do that
when you have a partial basis when you
have set of orthogonal lengths on
vectors
you can always complete it to a basis we
choose some completion containing the so
it contains the first all single vectors
such a basis exists why you should know
that so then now the proof is very
simple for T equals 1 to r AV T is Sigma
u T so let's write this down
so AVT let me know by definition is
Sigma T UT that's the definition of UT
how about B V T so be VP is equal to sum
over all T prime let's call it 1 2 or so
B I'm going to write down just B itself
Sigma T prime t prime this is B and I'm
multiplying it by V T so this is an
inner product by the way that's not true
for outer products which we'll see later
this is an inner product so it's 0
unless T equals T prime 0 or T prime not
equal to T since the V T or orthogonal
so I should recall and we will see that
next time V T VT prime transpose is not
0 even if T is not equal to T prime
right so if these were both unit vectors
so 1 is the first unit vector and this
is the second unit vector for outer
product this is not 0 write this matrix
so yeah a little careful sometimes
that's going to come up but this is
inner product this is 0 so you get 0 for
everybody except T so you have Sigma T
okay and therefore that's true for the
first R and then for everybody else
AV T is zero because we had to stop at
our and B VT is also zero because those
are orthogonal peaks and B ends in B
engine a VT so the first one so that
proves that the singular value
decomposition theorem is true possible I
don't have
yeah okay good point so what happens is
yeah so right so we should check that
right
suppose I replace V T by minus VT then
UT will also get replaced by minus AV so
if I multiply this by minus one so will
you TB so then you're fine right because
this thing will stay the same the
product will say two minus one yeah
better you could flip or you could if
there are ties you could've chosen
anyone right so is that what you're so
for an invariant subspace I can choose
any basis so if there are the bunches
okay so it's sort of exactly like the
eigenvalue case if the top 100 singular
values are all the same
the unwanted dimensional space
consisting of the first hundred singular
vectors is in invariant subspace in some
things and you can choose any
orthonormal basis
yeah know-it-all so you think some of
Viti some overall T V T V T transpose
identity right it is for the space for
the R dimensional space if your only
these it will be the identity but it's
true that if you can hit it with the
minus 100 so it's also true that if
there are ties for the singular values
which can be then you can choose any
basis of this you can do rotation yeah
and it's not really ever the one is
better than the other one but you can do
rotations so I should one one other
point I want to make
so what is nice about this as well as
spectral decomposition is is the
orthogonality is very nice right so if
for instance if I want a a transpose I
can write it as Sigma T UT VT transpose
now the transpose of this is also Sigma
T but VT comes in front right
now let's make this sum let's do the
index p1 here and t2 here to a white
confusion so that's equal to I can just
I can just multiply them out I get Sigma
T 1 Sigma T 2 u t1 V t1 we transpose me
this t2 we know you
okay this is zero we did this in the
product right this is zero unless t1
equals t2 so otherwise it's zero right 0
if T 1 not equal to t2 therefore this
becomes just t1 that we can call it T
Sigma T squared
same same thing as when you had a
spectral decomposition so if you have
lambda T UT UT of a symmetric matrix UT
UT transpose this is spectral
decomposition right and you can power
the matrix and the eigenvalues will
power but the eigenvectors remain the
same right and that's just by repeating
this kind of process right this is
extremely useful in a lot of contexts
actually one context very really useful
is Markov chains because if this is the
transition probability matrix PDEs as
the transition
probably matrix where steps and that the
eigenvalues just power the eigenvectors
just stay as they are which is very nice
that's also to a singular value
decomposition right because it's not
symmetric so you don't get okay so maybe
one last thing i'll say as an
application of SVD is very trivial in
some sense is if if a is invertible so
then it's d by d let's say then a equals
sum over T equals 1/2 D Sigma T u T V T
transpose all the Sigma T are nonzero
it's invertible they are all positive
there none of them is negative then a
inverse if T equals 1 to the 1 over
Sigma T same UT UT and the reason that's
true is we just check by multiplication
and if it's not invertible then R is
less than B you can do the same thing if
R is less than D then a is T equals 1 to
R Sigma T u TV T transport and you can
write what's called a pseudo-inverse
this is often written this way this is
pseudo inverse T equals 1 to R 1 over
Sigma T again u T V T transpose
oops sorry V T u T transpose V T UT for
same here
I wrote that wrong this should be V T
first and this acts like the inverse in
the space of a is equal to the identity
in the R dimensional space and it's
useful for a lot of purposes